une ville paralysée et un accueil
bruyant pour Emmanuel Macron en
déplacement à Vendôme pour échanger sur
les déserts médicaux avec des
professionnels de santé du territoire
c'est bien le sujet des retraites qui a
fait le plus de bruit ce mardi les
syndicats avaient appelé à se rassembler
pour l'arrivée du président plusieurs
centaines de personnes sont donc venues
munies de leur casserole Léa Turquie et
Clémence dosc Vendôme a retrouvé son
calme après une journée très mouvementée
pour la visite du président de la
République il y a quelques heures ici se
trouvaient plusieurs centaines de
manifestants Emmanuel Macron ne les a
peut-être pas vu mais il les a très
certainement entendus ils étaient tenus
à distance avec un périmètre de sécurité
et s'était donné rendez-vous depuis midi
à proximité de la maison de santé de
Vendôme pour eux le passage en force de
la réforme des retraites n'a toujours
pas été digéré je suis venue parce que
depuis le début je trouve que cette
réforme c'est absolument une injustice
ça réforme des retraites bon ça
participe d'un des tricotage gonfler de
notre système social est-ce qu'on est
dans la continuité de l'action dès que
le président ou les membres de
gouvernement les milices veulent aller
sur le terrain Bana on est là pour leur
faire voir que on est toujours aussi
alors réforme faudrait un truc il revoit
sa façon de gérer le pays de faire la
démocratie parce que là il s'inspire un
petit peu trop de Marine Le Pen
l'arrivée du président de la République
s'est faite sous haute surveillance la
ville de Vendôme s'est retrouvée
complètement paralysée des CRS et
gendarmes faisaient barrage autour du
périmètre de sécurité les manifestants
eux ont pris place sur les voies ferrées
pour se rapprocher au maximum de la
maison de santé et surtout pour se faire
entendre une ambiance très bruyante qui
contraste avec un autre rassemblement à
quelques centaines de mètres de là eux
sont venus soutenir Emmanuel Macron en
soutien le fait de la visite du
président Macron aujourd'hui à la mlspu
il y a des réformes à faire il y a des
pas mal de soucis dans ce pays en dehors
des retrait es et c'est pas en tapant
dans des casseroles qu'on va faire
avancer les problèmes d'inflation de
climat et tout ce que toute la liste que
vous connaissez et bien le président est
venu aborder la problématique des
déserts médicaux avec le personnel de la
maison de santé de Vendôme un échange
auquel seul une poignée de journalistes
ont pu assister une chose est sûre cette
visite axée santé a vite été rattrapée
par la question brûlante des retraites